we learn to the idea of you having like
two values or two quantities if you like
and they are important to consider
because they're related and what we call
a linear fashion right hence Olivia
relationships okay so what that would
mean is if one increased or decreased
the other one would increase or decrease
in the same proportion that's a really
important time to young things happen in
the same proportion that's kind of what
Olivia means really we also spent some
time or you also spent some time
thinking about what that would look like
if you plug it so easy example when you
guys have looked at before money earned
your first setbacks is there it doesn't
need to be huge if it's a pretty simple
graph might and if we take that value
that quantity and we compare it against
ours worked that would be a pretty
common-sense thing to compare it in
order to graph it against strength so
you work twice as long you need twice as
much right so for example if you have I
don't know what so what's a pretty
decent hourly rate these days eight a
button for doing what for do bag is 10
okay let's do intense that's nice around
20 here 14
so if we plot some points along here
okay for instance if we said Ted Knowles
it out right yeah if you white twice as
long as we've said you get twice as much
money three times look at this yet the
idea okay importantly you get with a
linear relationship right is that if we
join all these off together despite the
fact that I've only put in whole numbers
on there all those values in between
still exists right if you worked two and
a half hours okay
so that'll be here wouldn't it and sure
enough you earn $25 yeah and you could
take any open spot you between there
between what anywhere along this line
that's what you would do okay I think
you went further you thought about
gradient and what that means in this
case by the way suppose I did put
another line on here with a steeper
grade something like if the green II was
steeper what would that correspond to in
terms of real-world language like what
could you say about this this green
person versus this new person yep
yeah good okay that's what you just said
ready then up a steeper gradient that's
okay see the green it corresponds to a
faster rate I'm only mine right but it's
still the same proportion these are both
leaving okay